here's what would happen if you never  threw anything away  never tossing things out would be a huge  change for society it would help keep  things like single-use Plastics  packaging and fast food waste out of our  oceans landfills and the environment as  a whole you'd need to Pivot towards  reusable shopping bags and take out  containers  since consumers are responsible for 60  percent of the greenhouse gas emissions  and up to 80 percent of the world's  water use this would be a welcome change  for the planet the repair industry would  Skyrocket DIY activities would increase  in popularity and you'd have fun  customizing your kitchen or building  that backyard deck you always wanted  people would start borrowing and trading  goods and we might become less obsessed  with upgrading our homes we would even  use garbage or leftover items to build  houses you wouldn't want to become a  hoarder but it could help make us shop  more consciously so